>> IN HIS FIRST FACE-TO-FACE
MEETING WHICH I WAS PRESIDENT
SINCE -- TOOK OUT HIS NAME
BECAUSE I CAN PRONOUNCE IT --
[LAUGHTER]
-- PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CHANCE OF
ASSERTING ON CHINA'S POLICY
GOING OUT THE WINDOW.
THROUGHOUT THE THREE HOUR
MEETING, BIDEN LEAVING OUT TWO
CONVENIENT ISSUES: FENTANYL
FLOWING INTO THE U.S. FROM
CHINA, AND WHERE COVID CAME
FROM.
INSTEAD, BIDEN PUTTING CLIMATE
CHANGE FRONT AND CENTER.
>> President Biden: THE WORLD
EXPECTS CHINA AND THE
UNITED STATES TO PLAY KEY ROLES
IN THESE GLOBAL CHALLENGES, FROM
CLIMATE CHANGES TO FOOD
INSECURITY, AND FOR US TO BE
WILL TO WORK TOGETHER.
>> FOOD INSECURITY.
WHILE BIDEN IS RUBBING ELBOWS
OVERSEAS, HERE IS WHY HE SHOULD
BE PRESSING CHINA ON FENTANYL.
THIS WEEKEND, COPS BUSTED A
NEW YORK CITY MAN WITH 20,000
HILLS.
HOURS LATER, HE WAS RELEASED
WITHOUT BAIL, PROBABLY WENT ON
TO DO VOLUNTEER WORK.
WHO KNOWS WHERE HE WENT?
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK, DID JOE
BLOW IT?
>> IN MY OPINION YESTERDAY, HE
DID.
THE HISTORY BOOKS MIGHT GO "THAT
WAS SMART, BECAUSE HE'S TRYING
TO CALM THINGS DOWN, MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
MISCOMMUNICATIONS AND END UP IN
A WAR OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND
THEN SAY "ITS SOBER MINDED."
I REMEMBER IN 2020 WHEN HE LEFT
FOR ELECTION, AND SAID HE WOULD
HOLD CHINA MORE ACCOUNTABLE THAN
TRUMP WOULD, IN THAT IT WAS ALL
OF THESE ATTACK ADS.
BIDEN HAS NOT SEEN XI SINCE HE
BECAME PRESIDENT.
I KNOW THERE IS -- THE ISSUE
THAT KILLED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS, LOST A GENERATION OF
KIDS, COST THEM THEIR EDUCATION,
THEIR FUTURES, THEIR JOBS, THEIR
LIVELIHOODS, AND THAT'S NOT THE
FIRST THING YOU SAY THAT YOUR
PRESS CONFERENCE TO AMERICA?
AFTER THE MEETING -- I HOPE IT
CAME UP, BECAUSE CHINA UNLEASHED
A GLOBAL PANDEMIC ON THE WORLD,
AND NOBODY HAS SEEN HIM FOR TWO
YEARS.
I THINK THAT TODAY, THAT WAS A
DISAPPOINTMENT.
>> AND THEN YOU ADD TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT BEING KILLED
BY COVID, BEING KILLED BY PILLS.
THEY ARE YOUNG PEOPLE, A LOT OF
THEM ARE HEALTHY -- 120,000
PEOPLE -- AND THIS COULD APPEAL
TO JOE BY SAYING THAT THESE
COULD BE YOUR VOTERS THAT MAY BE
MIGHT CARE.
>> WHAT ABOUT HIS SON?
HIS SON HAS A DRUG ADDICTION, SO
HE SHOULD TAKE THIS MORE
SERIOUSLY.
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, HE SAID XI
WAS A THUMB WHO RAN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, AND WILL
NOT BE AFRAID TO SEND B-52
BOMBERS.
NOW HE'S MR. SOFTY WITH
ICE CREAM, "LET'S TALK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE."
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT TALK ABOUT
WHETHER THE RUSSIANS HAD DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP AND THAT WAS MAY BE
AFFECTING HIS POLICIES?
WHY DON'T WE EVER HEAR ABOUT
MAYBE THE FACT THAT THE CHINESE
HAVE DIRT ON JOE BIDEN, IF
THAT'S AFFECTING HIS POLICIES?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE PRESSURE
DONALD TRUMP WAS UNDER TO
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO CONFRONT
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO HIS FACE?
HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
INTERFERING IN THE ELECTION?
DID YOU ASK HIM IF HE
INTERFERED?
AND HE SAID "I DID IT" SECTION -
AND THERE WAS NO PRESSURE,
EXCEPT MAYBE FROM THIS SHOW, FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO CONFRONT XI ON
THESE DEATHS.
IF YOU ARE ADDING COVID AND
FENTANYL, YOU ARE ADDING OVER
MILLION AMERICAN DEATHS.
TO SAY THAT A POLICE STATE, A
SURVEILLANCE STATE, HAS NO CLUE
WHO IS SENDING SYNTHETICS TO
NORTH AMERICA FOR MAKING THE
PILLS -- COME ON!
THEY HAVE NO IDEA THAT THIS
VIRUS CAME FROM A LAB?
FIRST THEY BLAME THE AMERICANS,
THEN THE AUSTRALIA, AND THEN
THIS MARKET, BURNED IT, THEN
REBUILT THE WET MARKET.
THE INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES THAT
JOE BIDEN IS TASKED WITH FINDING
OUT WHETHER IT SPRANG FROM THIS
LAKE, THEY ALL OF A SUDDEN
COULDN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S LIKE 50/50.
THESE GUYS KNOW IF PUTIN HAS
CANCER, KNOW WHEN SOMEONE'S
EMAIL IS HACKED.
THEY COULD PUT A MISSILE THROUGH
A WINDOW 50,000 MILES AWAY.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT CAME FROM A
LAB!
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THE JACKET
THEY WEAR?
WHAT IS WITH THAT JACKET?
>> WHICH JACKET?
>> THAT ONE HE'S WEARING, WHAT
IS THAT?
>> EVERY TIME THEY GET
TOGETHER -- THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
PAINFUL EXPERIENCES THAT ANY
PRESIDENT HAS TO GO THROUGH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD TO TOO.
YOU HAD TO DON THE TRADITIONAL
OUTFIT OF THE COUNTRY HOSTING.
IT'S A CULTURAL, DIPLOMATIC
THING.
IT'S NICE TO DO BUT IT ALWAYS
LOOKS A LITTLE AWKWARD.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THAT.
THAT LOOKS LIKE THE PERFECT
LOUNGE RARE WHEN YOU ARE HAVING
A MARTINI.
--
LOUNGEWEAR.
DON'T YOU AGREE, THAT'S A
MARTINI JACKET?
ISN'T IT OBVIOUS THAT NOBODY IN
POWER WANTS TO KNOW COVID'S
ORIGINS?
OR ELSE WE WOULD.
ALL OF THE MUST BE CULPABLE.
>> AND WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU A
QUESTION MARK ABSOLUTELY!
IT IS GAIN
GANG OF FUNCTION, G-A-M-G
--
IT'S BECAUSE OF OUR COMPLICITY.
CAN I KEEP GOING?
JESSICA, DO YOU WANT TO GO?
>> MY NAME WAS CALLED BUT I TOOK
A PASS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AND SORRY >> GAINING --
>> HERE IS THE THING:
PIERS MORGAN THIS MORNING SAID
SOMETHING VERY INTERESTING.
HE SAID THAT -- THIS MORNING
WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUT BIDEN,
WHEN LAST SUMMER HE MET
VLADIMIR PUTIN, LOOKED DOWN, AND
HE TOLD HIM "DON'T DO ANYTHING,
DON'T YOU GO INVADING UKRAINE."
AND HONESTLY PUTIN REALLY LISTEN
TO HIM -- OBVIOUSLY STARTED
LISTENING TO HIM AND THEN
INVADED UKRAINE.
BY TELLING XI JINPING THAT WE
ARE NOT IN A COLD WAR, CLEARLY
NOT IN A COLD WAR, THEY WILL BE
DOING THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT
HE SAYS.
BIDEN TALKS ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS,
AND CHINA'S POSSIBLE ABUSE OF
HUMAN RIGHTS, BUT HE DOES NOT
TALK ABOUT THE HUMAN RIGHTS OF
AMERICANS WITH THE FENCE AND ALL
THAT'S COMING OVER HERE AS WELL
AS THE COVID.
BIDEN TALKED A FEW MONTHS AGO
ABOUT U.S. SANCTIONS ON CHINESE
DRUGMAKERS, AND TO THE ADDICTION
EPIDEMIC.
I PULLED IT UP TODAY.
IT'S THAT HE WAS GOING TO
DISRUPT THE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN
AND DISRUPT NETWORKS THAT --
OPIOIDS THAT REACHED THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY NAMED ONE GUY.
THEY PUT UP A REWARD OFFER OF
$5 BILLION FOR THE ARREST OF
THIS GUY.
HE'S NEVER BEEN ARRESTED.
THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD
IMPOSE SANCTIONS ON ALL OF THESE
FOREIGN COUNTRIES, AND THE ORDER
ALLOWS THEM TO TARGET FOREIGN
DEALMAKERS DIRECTLY RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON HOTELS.
IT'S NONSENSE, WORDS, DOESN'T
MEAN ANYTHING.
EVERYTHING HE SAYS, HE'S GOING
TO DO ON AN INTERNATIONAL SCALE.
NO ONE BELIEVES HIM AND NO ONE
IS AFRAID OF HIM.
>> JESSICA, END SECTION WITH
SHEER BRILLIANCE.
>> NO ONE IS EVER SATISFIED WITH
WHAT A WORLD LEADER DOES.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
COVER EVERY SINGLE IMPORTANT
TOPIC, AND TOP OF THE LIST, IT
WAS THE AGGRESSION SURROUNDING
TAIWAN AFTER NANCY PELOSI
DECIDED TO GO.
THERE WAS BIPARTISAN CONCERN AND
SUPPORT FOR HER TO GO THERE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THEY
HAD TO TALK ABOUT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A CONVERSATION ON
HUMAN RIGHTS, YOU TALKED NOT
ONLY ABOUT WHAT GOES ON WITHIN
CHINA, BUT TIBET AND -- IT IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD, AND HAS
BEEN A PROBLEM ABOUT CONFRONTING
CHINA ABOUT THEIR HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES.
AND HOW CHINA IS PISSED OFF
ABOUT THE TRADE SANCTIONS THAT
WE HAVE PUT WITH SEMICONDUCTORS.
THAT IS A HUGE STRIKE AGAINST
CHINA, AND AGAIN, BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THAT.
ANOTHER NOTCH IN
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BELT WHEN IT
COMES TO GETTING THINGS DONE.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT THAT
EVERYBODY IS RUNNING AWAY FROM
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
ORIGINS OF COVID, AND I'M SURE
IT IS BECAUSE MANY WESTERN
DEMOCRACIES ARE INVOLVED IN THIS
RESEARCH, AND WE KNOW THAT TO BE
TRUE, CERTAINLY ABOUT OURSELVES,
BUT TO PAINT THIS AS A PICTURE
OF COMPLETE CAPITULATION, AND
SHOWING UP TO SAY "WHAT IS YOUR
SKIN REGIMENTS" OR SOMETHING,
THAT IS ABSURD.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT REAL
TOPICS, AND I UNDERSTAND WHY
TAIWAN -- THEY WERE UNIFIED
AGAINST PUTIN, TALKING ABOUT WHO
HE CANNOT USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON,
AS WELL AS ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
ON IN NORTH KOREA, AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS TO HAVE OUT
THERE, IS THAT THE U.S. AND
CHINA ARE UNIFIED ON THAT FRONT.
>> IT IS A THREE HOUR
CONVERSATION, SQUEEZED IT IN AT
THE END.
>> WALKING OUT THE DOOR AND SAYS
"NO MORE FENCE AND ALL."
SPEAK OF THE THAT FIGURED IT
OU